standing at the heart of our towns and
cities for hundreds of years our rich
history of house building has quietly
come to say a lot about who we are and
where we live it talks about our
national identity it says things about
what we're good at and what what a
meaningful to us homes West space and
light mattered still highly sought after
centuries later compare and contrast
that to what we see today with a chronic
shortage of accommodation Britain is in
a race to bills with row upon row of cut
and paste designs constructed by a
handful of volume house builders
anonymous boxes relentless I think the
lesser copybook that we see so often I
of the same thing just been rolled out
across the country is really damaging by
the mid-2020s the government wants to be
building 300,000 homes a year which is
why we're seeing a lot more of this and
if you ask people how they feel about it
they all seem very uniform they're not
particularly exciting to look at in the
new developments I've got a 17 year old
he's terrified of whether he'll ever be
able to afford after uni to live where
he's been brought up I'm not sure they
take into consideration the the
infrastructure just seems to be housing
estate after housing estate those who
aren't fans are often accused of
NIMBYism but did they have a point it's
what we're building some things we can
be proud of in the same way we look back
at Victorian era or even mark South
Gates is a chartered Town Planner with
over 30 years experience I really did
assume that every single development
would have to in some way have included
it there will have been some
architecture in the design to start off
with but once they've got a starter
house type then actually they're just
repeating their house type I mean we
talk about a look and feel of a place it
is something about fearless how does it
fit does it feel sort of enough lots of
emotive words yeah does it feel safe
comfortable like there's a lot of homes
here
we have a quick look welcome to the
valley of the bins people need bins
people need to put those bins somewhere
but I actually put them in what is the
focal point between the properties it's
almost creating barriers then there's
the tarmac that runs right up to your
front door there's no space out the
front at all really it's soulless is the
world I view so it feels a bit you know
it just doesn't feel like it it's just
not as good as it could have been now
one of the problems with our housing
model is for a lot of the developers
they but they build they sell they have
no long-term interest and therefore they
aren't interested in that long-term bit
of course if you're a first-time buyer
you're probably just grateful to be on
the property ladder and they're not bad
but many don't come close to matching
the quality or ambition of Britain's
great tradition of home building the
quality of our housing really is not
nearly good enough much of it shouldn't
be built at all of that which is built
at least half means really substantial
improvements but the Home Builders
Federation which represents private
developers in England and Wales says its
members shouldn't be criticised for
things like road design or access to bin
storage as that's in the hands of the
local highway authorities it says if
there's a level of standardization in
what we're seeing it's to keep supply
chain costs down for customers and
builds are always have a standard
quality and design that builds us no
customers want to live in then there are
the new homes coming on the market that
aren't built from scratch in Croydon
you'll find quite a lot of these office
blocks turned into flats frequently
falling far short of national space
standards these tiny homes don't even
need planning permission there's a
strange shape it was an at West Bank I
think it was their sort of logo and the
developers done the minimum amount
possible really to convert it into
residential use so it still looks like
an office building still got these
tinted windows you can't open that don't
offer very much natural light developers
have been allowed to convert offices
into residential properties ever since
2013 when changes to permitted
development rules were introduced to cut
down on red tape in some of the
interviews we conducted people were
describing them as slums of the future
and I think that's quite reasonable
description of more than 240,000 homes
that were finished between 2018 and
nineteen twelve percent came through
change of use conversions one of the
good arguments for planning control is
that the the market sometimes fails and
when you leave things entirely to the
whim of the market sometimes you'll get
good quality developments but in a
majority of cases you won't if people
think it's profitable to do a poor
quality design so what was here was a
was a sort of classic 1960s development
there are still some pockets of
brilliance on the developments we're a
little more thought is put in you can
see by the the different building
heights that we've really tried to
integrate it architect and government
design advisor Sadie Morgan says it's
not necessarily about spending more
I don't believe bright you know good
design costs extra and in the end I
think that the the benefits the wider
benefits that it brings to society we
can't underestimate the importance of
improving people's quality of life
I think developers and developing
companies have deep pockets and they
have top-notch barristers that can
really sort of bully and push through on
what they want but actually we have to
we as architects have to help everyone
resist and the Royal Institute of
British Architects tried to give a
platform to what works
Brentford Lough West development has won
numerous awards for its intelligent
design incorporating old canal
architecture but developments like these
are the exception to the rule it's very
clearly demonstrated that the those
companies have used and played the need
for housing as a reason to not ask them
to build to higher environmental
standards which we think is terrible and
they should really be held to account it
doesn't cost that much more
there should be an ethical
responsibility on our house builders to
be coming up with designs that stand the
test of time homes we feel proud of
places we want to stay it's not so much
about whether or not you like the look
of that new development down the road
but whether or not enough thought has
gone into how it affects the local
community so that those who move in feel
pulled up by their surroundings rather
than dragged down if we want future
generations to look back and admire what
we've built in the same way we do the
Victorians the Edwardian the Georgians
then design really matters because what
we're building now is a legacy we all
have to live with Katie Spencer Sky News